this is a production of Cornell
University yes I indeed have had dinner
with John Prime and we can talk about
that um so I am absolutely delighted and
um to be able to talk about the small
farms program the way that we're leaning
into and and uh trying to grow equity
and
agriculture um and uh what I am hoping
to do also is perhaps uh invite you to
be in collaboration with us as we lean
into this work going so I thought it
would be good to start with just what is
a small farm since our program is
focused on uh building the viability of
small farms um and so we worked with the
definition that USDA has sort of set out
originally and that these are farms that
are grossing less than $350,000 a year
that the majority of the labor on the
farm comes from the family or a small
group of
managers um and that um uh that the the
the land area doesn't matter this actual
physical footprint of the farm isn't
relevant because some Farms that are say
C grain can be quite large and fit
within a small farm and then others that
are intensive vegetable production can
be quite small and still be large Farms
or Urban
PLS and so they have a mix of business
structures they um uh
uh can have a mix of different kinds of
Commodities that doesn't matter so I
just wanted to start with what a small
farm is because that almost ends up
being the question that everyone asked
me and the reality is that over 80 90%
of the farms in New York would be called
small in fact the
country and in New York over 80% of our
Farms are making less than $100,000 a
year in those so I just wanted you to
have a sense of who um would be included
in this audience
and so the program itself was started in
uh 2001 in response to a USDA uh report
called a time to act that focused on how
do we support small farms in Earth they
were already aware of the challenges of
being a small scale producer and and so
the USDA funded and supported programs
like this across the country and the one
at Cornell is one um that I think is
perhaps uh it's really well known for
our work in supporting small farms
there's other the ones that are at
Auburn University and then Oregon and
Washington State um but but we're the
ones that really leaned into this
work and so in 2001 the program was
started I became the director in
2004 and over the last 20 some years our
program has evolved and changed we've
gone from a staff of just two
people to 15 and so some of those folks
are here in the um room and some are
online but um I'm going to try very hard
to be pointing out these individuals as
I go through the talk so if you have
other questions about the different
projects and programs we do you can
follow up with those who are passionate
in leading this
support so um one of the things that has
been incredibly helpful um and a great
gift to us recently is that the program
now for our work and our history has
been supported by the state we are in
the governor's budget and that provides
us the ability to create some long-term
planning and some stability and to lean
into the work that I'm about to describe
to lean in with a long-term so we're
really grateful for that and none of
this is possible without collaboration
with a lot of other
organizations and so this is just a some
of the folks that we collaborate with
each one of the people on our team is
working with others many other groups in
order to do the work so we see ourselves
not only in providing direct education
um but also Network building and
connecting and that is a piece that
being here at Cornell really gives us a
a nice sort of global overview but also
a lot of opportunities to
connect one example of how we work
really collaboratively is through our
online courses and I don't know if
you're aware of it but um our program
has hosted an online course uh portfolio
for almost 20 years now uh we probably
have had thousands of people go through
our courses um and these are led by
Erica P and Cara um who's with us at the
program with some support from many
others including our comm's team Casey
and Jamie who are with us as well but
this is an example our instructors are
uh Educators within cornal cooperate
extension people that work with
nonprofits and Farmers themselves who
join us to teach others about how to do
various different
activities so what I wanted to do is
just sort of share with you um how we
see ourselves um in in that we provide
culturally appropriate resources
education research and networks to
support small farming is a dignified
viable and meaningful
livelihood um and and within that we are
deeply committed to equity and inclus
inclusivity this came up for us in the
work that we've done historically and
developing New farmers we knew that um
uh in the state there was a lot people
getting questions about how do we
support New farmers and so we helped
bring together a lot of these Educators
to create a whole platform and
collection of
materials and so New York has had a very
robust support system for New farmers
but when we look at he showing up we've
looked historically who's showing up um
um they're mostly white and so we
started to ask the question why is this
happening when on our online course PL
platform we see a lot of folks that are
registering that represent very diverse
communities and so that was just one way
in which we continue to focus and we're
reminded we have to be intentional in
the ways we try to cultivate um our
Outreach to for these diverse
communities and so I'm going to tell you
a lot more about that um because we want
to make sure that anyone and everyone
feels welcome in our
work so as you can imagine it's really
hard and again I'm just going to do a
quick overview of the program for those
of you who AR famili with us then dig
into the equity work
do um as you can imagine it's really
difficult to try to make priorities when
you're working with this large and
diverse group of farms so one of the
ways we've done that historically is to
host um a summit a Statewide Summit
where we work uh with Educators around
the um State and we host inperson and
online conversations that are the to
identify what are the priorities for
small farmers what do they need to see
what is the support that they want this
is an example of one that we hosted in
2017 that was focused on the future of
the livestock industry in the state one
of the outcomes we hope from these
efforts is that we can move legislative
action to support small farms and that
report was fundamental to securing State
support for new livestock
positions so um that's just an example
that we use in order to sort of Identify
some priorities and then develop teams
or sort of support teams that are
leading into it um not sure what Happ
okay so some of the projects that we
do um uh are highlighted on our website
and I would invite you to go there but
some of these have come through the
Summits and others have come through
direct conversation with different
stakeholders but our programs uh range
the gamut from directed sort of
technical support for example with Agro
forestries and mushroom production
invest vegetables and tillage urban egg
development to um community support and
I'm going to talk mostly about community
support our work with veterans where
we're really building networking
community and our work with latino
Farmers where we do both provide a
directed education but also create and
provide other kinds of support so um I
just wanted to highlight that there's a
lot of different places and we're always
looking for collaborators particularly
and connections and so students faculty
and anyone who is um interested in sort
of working with us on this work we would
welcome
that we also do research we've hosted um
all different kinds of research projects
over the year and we're continuing to
think carefully about how we want to
lean into research going forward um
we've done surveys of farmers to do
understand opinions and perspectives um
uh we did h a fairly intensive one
recently as part of the vision 2050
project which created a vision for New
York agriculture that we hope to achieve
by
2050 a qualitative re research around
farmer wellness and Latino farmer needs
as well as some uh scale appropriate
types of Production
Technologies and so this is just a to
point you to our website um and you can
find a lot of more information both at
our website we'll link you to the work
we do but then also our YouTube channel
where we have amazing collection of
videos I think the one with the most
views is of a pig getting castrated um
don't ask me why that gets the most
views but it's a pretty important task
if you have pigs
so but it's there's all sorts of um uh
we have uh Farmers telling their story
we have uh collections of different
types
of webinars that we've hosted as well as
directed conversations on particular
topics
so in this work as I mentioned
um we have become more and more aware of
um the need to be focusing carefully and
thinking more deeply about how we lean
into supporting equity and
Agriculture and as a program and for me
personally I feel like one of our roles
and one of our goals is to increase the
number of farmers in New York who aren't
white simply just what does that look
like how do we do that how do we do that
together um we this is not new work for
us um the first time I met um back in
2004 I met with black farmers in New
York City trying to figure out how do we
do this work um I went to the first bugs
conference to the black urban Growers
conference um we've hosted trainings for
service providers on how do we diversify
our programming for beginning Farmers
there's many different places that where
we've had touch points and supporting
and thinking about equity and
culture um and but I think a lot of
things changed with George
Floyd that incident and and the and so
the moment that we had in our history
and our our country's own Reflections
about racial Equity really provided us
with some more impetus to lean in more
directly but for me personally it really
started with my own family history I
don't know if you all know what that
thing is I'm playing with over there
that little black item that little thing
but I started my networking very
young but um my mom and my dad came to
this country as refugees in many ways
their lives were threatened in India
because of what they chose to do which
was fall in love and get married to each
other so we arrived here with nothing as
immigrants and refugees and that is my
history and my story and part of my
commitment to this work
my mother um is who inspired me to farm
and garden I mean I was in her hair and
bugging her so she gave me seeds and
plants and said go out there and make a
garden and I had no idea that that
experience would be so fundamental that
who I
am that connection to soil and plants so
what would make agriculture better to me
even though I get to do this every day
is seeing more faces like mine on all of
these National
magazines produ
grower right um small farm quarterly
which is sort of ironic since we
produced that but but
these but it's this kind of you know
visibility and and elevation that we
need in order to um actually make
welcome uh Farms of color and those that
have diverse identities in our
agriculture
um so I um I I
cannot under I cannot dismiss the the
the struggles that our farmers of color
face
today we have today in our own
communities examples of races at play
obstruction alienation
intimidation um and physical threats
that farmers that we know have faced
um just because that they don't fit what
we think is
a and so we cannot we cannot
underestimate that and even for our
Farmers that identify as lgbtq plus that
is we have no numbers for who those
farmers are and I'll talk a little bit
about
that but these false constructs are
deeply embedded in the history of
Agriculture and there's so many ways in
which we are are dealing with that on a
day-to-day basis
so I just wanted to make sure I uplift
that and I experience but I also want to
say that um it's hands in soil to me
that are where we connect deep it is
that joy that we have for feeling soil
or dealing growing plants or growing
animals and in doing this work we call
farming is where we have common ground
and every farmer I've spoken to no
matter their identities no matter their
race just feel this joyful connection to
land and to farming and to what they're
doing for their communities and that
unifies us and that's what we want to
make
Elevate so where do we start um well
this is the 2017 data from the national
a statistics for New York and so we
start here because we want to know where
we go from here
and in that um uh in in the 2017 census
Farmers could report the people involved
in management in two ways there's the
primary producer which is the top line
the person filling it out who is sort of
seen as the farm sort of lead and then
up to four producers people that are
contributing to the management of that
farm well you can see
overwhelmingly um most of the Farms are
managed by individuals who would
identify as white um and then you the
same hold TRS for producers but when we
look at um the other
um races that are identified here what
we see is that less than 2% of our Farms
would be operated by
farmac if we look at just the First
Column which list Hispanic we have
55,000 or more Latino Hispanic
identified individuals that support our
agriculture in the state today and less
than 600 that are are reported on the
census that's less than
1% so these individuals who are deeply
committed to agriculture who have a
lifetime of Agriculture where who are
incredibly talented in supporting the
Farms that uh support all of us have had
very little entrance and opportunity to
become the entrepreneurs that they
really want to be so we'll talk about
them we make the maps with this data
because we thought well if we're trying
to lean into how we support increasing
diversity where are those Farmers around
the state and in fact it's interesting
because we found clusters of farmers um
in in um Clinton County St Lawrence
County down in Orange County which you'd
expect be close to the city um uh and
then Skyler County some surprising
places and so um trying to identify what
makes those places um welcoming to
different Farmers or is it just that
people are reporting more we're not sure
so um we've been trying to think
of work with um we've had some
conversations with our corporative
extension offices in those areas but
it's not easy to actually go out and ask
uh people like oh are you where are the
black farmers in this space because
people don't necessarily want to be
self-identified and so we're taking the
approach of trying to build
relationships to build trust in order to
invite people to join us in process in
education in learning and networking
this is a different way that we've math
this and I'm happy to share these with
anyone um we can't wait for the
2024 the 2022 census to come out it'll
be out next year in May so we can see
where we've gone over the last five
years so um again trying to um uh build
to figure out how do we lean in to
support a more diverse agriculture we've
been thinking about it but so as a
markets New York State Department of
agots hosted a diversity racial Equity
working group and I served on that along
with Ben Holton Holton and Julie Suarez
from Cornell and it included researchers
Educators Farmers themselves nonprofit
representatives to identify what were
the critical uh needs to support more
Farmers that color in the state they had
21 recommendations that could be
summarized as these four categories
access to infrastructure Education and
Training capital and
land but what's interesting is that
those are the common needs of most
beginning
Farmers but what they need is more
diligence and accountability on how
those resources are actually committed
and managed for Farmers
of that's the next level they can't not
just be General Grant
programs so as I mentioned earlier since
20 01 is a program we've been trying to
support um more
um uh work related to uh elevating the
needs and interests of deps of colors
and on campus we've been doing this in
different
ways uh the pandemic sort of as I
mentioned sort of slowed things down but
one of the things we were able to do is
I collaborated with Gerard a iching from
the uh rural Humanities and we hosted an
underground railroad seminar for black
farmers in New York so invited black
Farmers from across the state to meet up
and they met every week and they read
all of the books that the students were
reading in the class on campus but it
was um a intense conversations of
looking at
history to inform the
present amazingly profound conversations
among these individuals that are trying
to farm in their
communities and it was a gift that I
didn't even know what was I had no idea
what was going to happen and it was it
was a space that was just for them
nobody else was invited there was no
witnessing happening there was people
that were present in this dialogue about
what have we learned from history and
what has changed what really hasn't
changed so really cool job and then um I
and Gerard offered a rural Humanity
seminar and in that seminar we had uh
students do internships with
organizations around the stud so was
really amazing to have students students
on campus connecting and this is there's
so much opportunity for more of this
going
forward we've also done some work where
we've hosted uh different black Scholars
and leaders to come to campus virtually
or in person and share their work uh we
had Karen Washington who is a longtime
farmer here in New York but also mcarthy
fellow she's been she's known
internationally for her work in urban
farming and then Natalie basil who
authored we are each other's heart
harvest in Queen sugar I don't know if
anyone's seen that special um sub TV
channel I don't know which but um uh we
had a really beautiful and Powerful
conversation about why black land
matters um and then we hosted Monica
white Dr Monica white author of Freedom
farmers and then most recently last year
we had Dr Dale Myers on campus with her
du film rhythms of the land so those are
the ways in which as a program we're
trying to be cultivating these
conversations on campus
while we also reach out to support
what's happening off campus with these
communities so you'll see here this list
of different things that are happening
to support that things that we know have
to happen to support more black Farmers
for example and but it doesn't matter
what racial identity we're talking about
I think one of the pieces that's super
important on this is
finding mentors individuals who are from
that identity to be teaching training
and supporting and that's one thing that
we don't have on our landscape yet are
those individuals that are ready and
able to support it those ways so we need
to find others who are able and willing
to to be in community and to build
trust so I wanted to just take a moment
and step way out because I think that um
there there's some things that we have
to be aware of that affect our ability
to do this work effectively and I want
to to share um something I learned from
a research project I worked on called
the farming and food narrative project
that project was aimed at trying to
figure out what are some sticky new
metaphors we could use talk about
agriculture with a non-farming public to
help them uh actually better understand
Agriculture and how to invest and
support the farm build frankly or other
sorts of initiatives and policy measures
that are important and the group we
worked with talked about cultural models
trying to these are like the
commognitive shortcuts that we all use
to to manage all of the information
coming at us or to understand our
environment so um they are learn through
years of experience and they tend to be
shared across our culture or a dominant
culture these different types of models
and we use them like I said to organize
information well we wanted to understand
what are the cultural models that frame
farming and Farmers that was part of
like trying to understand how we use
some
messaging so if you were to close your
eyes right now and imagine what a farm
is just think about Farm what's an ideal
Farm I asked
Google and these are the images that
come
up the very idealized bucolic image of a
red barn and a holen cow some animals
grazing really clean straight rows of
crops right frankly you and I would stop
to take a a picture of a farm like this
because there are not that many of them
that are this perfect but yet this these
are the sorts of images that govern what
agriculture is I think that this is a
problem it's a problem because it makes
invisible the complexity of farming it
makes invisible the diversity of
approaches like there's no Greenhouse
operations here there's no Urban farms
in these images of how people think of
what a farm is there's no Diversified
Vegetable Farms there that may bead but
this is um but they also then they they
Infuse Us in agriculture with a sense of
competition because suddenly we're not
visible and it you I think in some ways
this mental cultural model fuels a bit
of division the question of what's a
real farm what's large why large versus
small there's only 2% of people involved
in agriculture in this country yet the
whole why do we create divisions why are
we trying trying to sort of
separate I think some of it comes from
cultural models of what's the way that
farming is framed in our general
site similarly if you were to think
about who is a
farmer think it who comes
up well
I could if I could eliminate one image
from our sort of agricultural expan
would be
because what are the adjectives that you
use to describe this
person these this couple I mean they're
so
boring and bored looking right I just um
you know I I feel like that image is
like it's trapped in the minds of so
many well lucky for us there are people
who have actually spoofed on that to
bring some humor into this but the power
of that image is huge what we learned in
our research is that farming in the
public from uh this is some social
scientists we collaborated with farming
is wrot simple formulaic trial and error
and farmers are
simpletons individuals that do a lot of
hard labor um to try and but there
they're buffeted by The Winds of
whatever comes out them well all of the
farmers I know are incredibly creative
hardworking individuals yes but they do
deliberate things to manage their risks
they are not people that sit by and not
make good decisions towards their
Futures and so this is a problem in the
way that the world is seeing agriculture
but these cultural models affect all of
us as well because they create these
they show up as ways of resistances when
we're in our work and doing our work we
Face them all the time time in trying to
rationalize and justify what we
do and in terms of small scale farming I
think it's um such an important piece
because these individuals who are doing
direct
sales they have the opportunity to
completely contradict that cultural
model that frame they can reinvent and
redescribe agriculture because they're
the direct they're the face of
Agriculture so many ways yet their value
is often undermined in our general
agricultural community
a small you know marginal whatever but
yet they're the ones that are actually
talking with people meeting with people
and have that chance of of contradicting
that and so I um I bring up this idea of
cultural models because I feel like we
have to be alert to them if we're really
wanting to do this work there's the work
we do on a day-to-day basis but this
larger sort of all of there's the all of
the issues of race racism and Equity but
then just the ways we're making our
decisions of what agriculture is and
when we participate in those like what I
don't want to ever see on the small
farms program is a pretty picture of a
farm in I want to see gritty I want to
see real and because I don't want us to
be collaborating with that image because
it doesn't do a
service so as I mentioned earlier um
talking a little bit more about um
Agriculture and how do we come back to
Bringing more diversity to agriculture
well as you can imagine if we really
want to see more farmers of color many
of these are going to be individuals
that come from Urban farming
experiences they're going to be um
having suddenly discovered farming and
discovered growing food in in a
community where they're being witnessed
by a lot of people in their community
that look like them and AR and are are
similar to them but then they get the
bug and they're ready to scale up and
Urban Land is very
tight so they start to look to move to
rural places and then they end up coming
into a place and landing in a rural
place where they don't fit the dominant
cultural model of who is a
farm and they don't have those social
networks or
connections so they feel that
alienation they may even come against
some
intimidation when we talk about support
in new farms and we always focus in on
those four topics access to land access
to Capital Access to infrastructure and
networks but we rarely talk about having
access to a really supportive
community and so it makes me think a lot
about right to farm and right to farm is
protects farmers who might have
neighbors who sort of show up in their
neighborhood and they move to rural
places because I think it's beautiful
but then they're some not so happy with
something they smell or something they
see so right to farm protects the right
to be able to do
farming how do we lean into safe to
farm where an individual can choose to
farm but not have to deal with nuisance
neighbors who don't necessarily like
what they
see this requires an entirely different
kind of support system one in which all
of us have to be intentional and to show
up
so supportive social networks that's not
new stuff and in fact I worked with a
bunch of social scientists on mapping
the networks of farmers how they work
together and what was so interesting in
that work was sort of understanding um
how these networks form and then how
they're organized and managed so we
asked we surveyed a bunch of farmer
networks in the Northeast and asked them
to tell us who do you go for information
then each of the dots on the map
represents an individual and the and the
lines that connect them are where they
go for
information so in this case we have a
social network um where you see some a
few connections between people maybe one
or two and there's some the bigger the
square the more dominant that person is
in the network for its
function here's one that is much more
robust there's a lot more connections a
lot of people are talking to each other
there's more people that are in the
middle that are sharing information they
become important resource h and then
here's another one this one there's a
huge Hive of activity that's going on
and connecting everybody uh but there's
still a few dominant characters in the
middle that if they disappeared it could
be a problem for
this so this is a way of visualizing
connections and how do we visualize and
then you can make intention to build the
ways though people are connected in that
Network the first one was one that was
led by two extension educators and two
years after our project that
dissolved the second one is a
Cooperative that continues today super
vibrant uh Cooperative of Growers this
one is a farmer-to-farmer Learning
Network that is responsible for the
majority of organic grain production in
New
York and it continues today it's been in
existence for over 20 years so how do we
get into a building intentional networks
and so I want to share with you some
examples for us
in how we think about this at the
Cornell small farms program and we do it
by trying to build we can provide the
information the knowledge the the
resources the information to do farming
but the other thing that we know we have
to do to support diversity is really
think intentionally how we build these
networks supportive networks where
people can feel safe they can feel like
they have a collaborative
serle and we do this with many different
communities but I'm going to highlight
four we do um and then uh we can sort of
have a conversation after
that our farm Ops program um and Nina
and Bailey pman are leading that um and
is has been built over several years and
providing veteran only spaces for people
to gather and talk learn from each other
and they connect from their own past
towards their own future these are
individuals that have many different um
skills and abilities that are perfectly
suitable to Agriculture and uh we
support them in discovering that we just
finished a onewe intensive training in
the Hudson Valley called arms of farm
and there's a buzz that continues from
those farmers who were there we're
hearing about it now
still um and and so this is one example
of where and and both n and Bailey are
have veteran connection and the Nino is
a veteran and Bailey is a veteran spous
they understand this group so they're of
the group and are able to represent and
connot um we as part of our um effort
with dealing and leaning into Equity our
Equitable Farm Futures initiative is
working across many different um uh
groups but particularly with latino
Latina latinx
Farmers this as I mentioned earlier
55,000 individuals supporting
Agriculture and only 600 actually
producing is just not
acceptable we can do
better and so uh our uh the program
itself our Furon egg program uh which
has four staff members that are fully
bilingual now buard Alvarado Tim shank
is here with us Maria Jose oo and Su
Valdez are all um hosting together uh
different types of training online
courses fully in Spanish part of our
online course portfolio and now has
Spanish first classes and resources and
materials uh we built out a part of our
website that is fully bilingual um and
we're very excited because um uh all all
of the efforts and the training have
have started to create a community that
continues to work together in one way
that they're working together is through
peer-to-peer farmer groups through hus
operos and that group uh around themes
around business planning and business
devel
folks are coming together and supporting
each other to think about how do we
better ourselves as
entrepreneurs and managers of other
people and
Farms but all of that is leading to
we're hosting the first ever Leo
agricultural conference in December
we're super excited because December 7th
and 8th this will be the first fully
Spanish it's a Spanish first conference
if you're interested in joining it our
bying
let us know uh we have folks coming from
all over the state and other parts of
the Northeast to be in this space which
centers the needs and interests of this
community so there's individuals who are
aspiring to farm who are already farming
who are work on
farms um that are going to be together
to imagine what does it look like to
have a Latino farmer organization in the
state or a greater
supportment an entirely different kind
of example
um is from our work with um mushroom
production and and we started out a
project that was funded by Nipa that was
meant to grow commercial mushroom
operations but what we learned very
quickly in some of the work in urban
spaces is that there's a lot of people
in have this passion for mushrooms but
they're not really interested in selling
them but they're really interested in um
in teaching others how to grow them and
so as a wonderful alternate protein
Source but then also for foraging and
other interests and growing on logs or
growing in bags um we recognized that
there was a different approach needed
and so created the community mushroom
Educators Network and that network has
gone to 146 different individuals across
the country now that have taken their
passion for growing mushrooms and are
sharing it in their communities delig
from that we've graduated people that
are sort of certified to be Educators um
and then eight of those are teaching
with us on our online
courses so um but you know you can see
from the
demographics that this is split between
individuals who would identify as white
and not because we know that the
community of people that are passionate
about this if they're going to grow into
commercial production we have to start
where they are and it may not be that
all of them are interested in farming
commercially but they will certainly be
able to support each other in exploring
that
and then the final example I'd like to
share um is uh around our bwell farming
project and reconnecting of
purpose and this project is in and this
work is entirely different because it
really centers
wellness and you may be surprised to
think of a small farms program doing
that but yet when we think about the
three pillars of
sustainability we are all focused so
heavily on economic or environmental but
yet the social pillar we kind of expect
to just happen by I don't know
sprinkling a little fairy dust and you
know a socially sustainable farm when
you see it we feel that you can
intentionally cultivate and reweave
social networks social Fabric and this
is one way that we're doing it with a
mix of farmers and so for example in um
Violet Stone leads us it's been inspired
and we're so grateful for Mara e sh's
work in helping us and Rec connect with
the center for cour Renewal that's at
the foundation of how we do this work um
but uh in our um reconnect with purpose
this brings together service providers
across many different races and at the
end of the last one where I was co-
teing this with Violet um two women who
identified as black sat down with me and
they said to me that when they walked
into this space they looked around the
room and they were like oh here we go
again
I here I am I represent and they were
like I had to hold myself back I had to
hold myself and of stance of protection
self-
protection and they said
now it was transforming because they
finally felt
seen they felt seen they felt like
people really saw them and completely
comfortable that happened because of
intention and it happened in creating
space and time for people to build
relationships so all of this is part of
how do we reweave our social fabric to
support diversity it's like being in
relationship with each
other
um the place that we want to build more
relationships is in working with our
native
communities and I hope you all are aware
of the land grab study that was
published in my country news which makes
a little challenging for a place like
Cornell to be saying I really want to
work with you when the lands of
supported our endowment were taken from
native communities around the
country but we um um Eric and I and um
many others in the extension are part of
a new project and we're really grateful
to be part of that of restoring
relationships and to go slow and to get
to know folks we spent time with hodon
and the cuga farm up in the Syracuse
area a few weeks ago and are looking
forward to what comes next
so that is how I just wanted to give you
all an overview of some of the ways as a
program all of us are leaning into
supporting a more diverse and Equitable
food system we know that the work will
be
slow but we also know it has to be
filled with intention and good mind and
good heart
uh it's not enough to just teach people
um what to do it's about where we create
a place for them to experiment and grow
as
individuals and so with that I would
love to end with a
poem I'm going to read it because I
think it sort of captures what we
do community somewhere there are people
to whom we can speak with
passion without having the words catch
in our
throats somewhere a circle of hands will
open to receive us eyes will light up as
we
enter voices will celebrate with us
where whenever we come into our own
power community means
strength that joins our strength to the
work that needs to be done arms to hold
us when we falter a circle of healing a
circle of
friends some place where we
can thank
you um I really love spread up about
representative agriculture you know what
people think of farmer or
grower but students want to get involved
what
invol so we U with the small farms
program we have u a lot of summer
student interns that we have and we host
and and so we're always welcoming folks
into that I've had graduate students so
sometimes there's a mix of that um and
historically um U there's a lot of
students that I've interacted with that
are on different internships like with
CCE but I'm open we're open to
conversation we welcome folks to be
collaborating with us even to be joining
us in our classes so one one exciting
development is uh we have a student
who's going to be teaching one of our
online classes Ayah she's going to be
teaching our soil health class talented
individual um and we're just really
excited for her to be able to share her
knowledge and wisdom with some of the
farmers that are really interested in
this world so we would welcome that as
well each of you has something to share
with
us thank you any other questions and you
you might uh ping Geneva as well if they
have
questions do that well you just say
Geneva Geneva do you have
questions and maybe
anyse yeah yeah so Anu I remember you
and I were talking about some
opportunity to work with black Farmers
vegetable farmers in New York and we
looked at the egg statistics from quite
a bit earlier than 2017 and saw that
they existed in principle but not part
of our networks weren't showing up at
meetings it just looked like a really
really hard problem it
is and I just have to say I am amazed
how far you've taken it not only
finding uh where they were that where
the potential farmers were what their
needs were building networks it's just
absolutely
outstanding so if anybody thought what
you did was easy uh really want to
dispel that well thank you Thomas but
I'm just gonna uplift the
team and all of our collaborators like
this is a joint effort none of this can
happen in isolation we are working
really hard to keep building these
Comm thank
you
yes isolation andion maybe like within
the farming
Community how you see consum ideas about
where our good comes from playing into
some of the challenges that
farmer you know it's so interesting that
you say that because feel like in some
ways where our food come from it can
play into this is where we have to
really Define that and deal with some of
those cultural models we have to be like
tell elevating stories and so I will say
that in in the B well farming in um
Retreats that we had we did both virtual
and online we had in person we had so
many new farmers who came and they came
because they felt isolated so farming in
itself is you know places and farming
you were kind of out there on your own
doing your thing but the power of
finding ways to connect and collaborate
I think is really important one of the
ways we're seeing emerging
collaborations particularly in the
Latino Latino Community is an interest
in a food
Hub and so trying to find a way to
collaborate to sell products because if
you're small scale you may not have
enough to go wholesale but together you
may have enough and then you can also
create with that a package and a story
and other things that are uh work on
behalf of
the so we're building and supporting
we're not building we're supporting the
building of this community and trying to
bring people together and our conference
is going to be one of those FS it's
third conference we we as Educators and
service providers are there to sort of
hold the
conversation but yeah that's one of the
aspiration in
certain other
questions yeah uh as somebody who worked
in a specific commodity based extension
program it always amazes me when people
work across a lot of different things so
uh my question is you know for specific
problems that emerge you know test
problem or cultural problem I mean how
do you connect with those sorts of
programs so we work like right now we're
working really closely with many
different partners particularly with
organizing this conference but we're
working with Workforce because we do
some work directly with people that are
employed on FMS and so do they so how do
we collaborate on that work uh we work
with IPM program and um hosting field
days for example that are Spanish first
what we need are people who speak
Spanish to be able to speak directly and
allow those participants to actually
communicate directly about the things
they're seeing and so we are still
providing the traditional Services of
sort of technical knowhow uh but wanting
to also complement that with um real
conversations real conversations that
can affect long-term change when we
started this work with the Latino
Community we had listening sessions had
90 Farm employees show up in this and
they had a list of what they wanted and
almost all of them said I want to speak
English better they they said that but
they wanted to be they saw it as a
secret to advancement a way for them to
advance their own interests and then
that is the language of business in this
country but they also wanted to um uh be
better managers they wanted to uh know
how to um work with computers so one of
the things that we do when we're um in a
training is we take iPads and
notebooks give people how teach them how
to use zoom so they can communicate with
each other differently but then be
collaborating and networking with us so
sometimes because this is a some of
these communities have a very different
history and um may not have the same
literacy that we're used to working with
we have to be creative in how we share
information you know and so that part of
it is a really important step is first
knowing who you're working with and
getting to know them and then being
really clear how to best share things
for them um
then and we uh one other thing we do is
we are finding Farmers that are
collaborating with us as Educators
they're of the
community and they know so that's a
really
well all righty okay great thank thank
everybody this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu